let's study the market for soda a little
bit
and so we're going to draw our
traditional axes so that is price
and
that is
quantity
and we have seen our classic supply and
demand curves
so this could be our upward sloping
supply curve at a low price not a lot of
people want to produce soda but as price
goes higher more and more people would
want to produce it and we could also
view that as a marginal cost curve that
first unit might be quite easy to
produce but then it gets a little bit
more and more expensive or costly to
produce as you have to hire and train
more people and get real estate for your
factories so you could also view this as
a marginal cost curve
and then on the demand side
we have our classic downward sloping
curve at a high price not a lot of
people are going to want the soda but
then as price gets lower a lot more
people are going to want the soda so
this is our demand curve which we could
also view as a marginal benefit curve
that first unit of soda a lot of
someone's going to get a huge benefit
for it and so they have a willing high
willingness to pay and then every
incremental unit people might just get a
little bit less benefit and so they have
a little bit less willingness to pay
which makes us downward sloping and so
we have our this we could also use the
marginal benefit curve and we have this
is all review
you would have your equilibrium quantity
that the market would produce and the
equilibrium price but now i'm going to
introduce a new idea because everything
we talked about here the marginal
benefit and the cost this was just the
marginal private benefit and the
marginal private cost it's not factoring
in society's benefits and costs and so
let me re-label this a little bit
instead of just saying marginal benefit
i'm going to call this the marginal
private benefit and instead of marginal
cost i'm going to call this the marginal
private cost
and this is the equilibrium price we
would get to if we just factored in the
private costs and benefits and this is
the equilibrium quantity if we just
factored in the private costs and
benefits and so i know what you're
thinking so that's nice sal but how do
we factor in the social benefits or cost
well for something like soda you could
have some negative social costs and when
you have negative social costs you would
call that a negative externality so
there are some negative
externalities
when you are thinking about soda it
could be that the cans cause pollution
that has to be cleaned up by society it
could be that all that sugar or corn
syrup inside of people's bloodstream
gives them diabetes
or decays their teeth
and society is going to have to pay for
it somehow and so another way to think
about it is we could add those negative
externalities to the marginal private
costs and we could get a marginal social
cost curve and so let me do that so if
we add the negative externalities
we get a marginal social cost curve so
this factors in the negative
externalities so i'll call this the
marginal social cost and let's say for
soda the private benefit just for
simplicity is equal to the social
benefit on the margin so i'll say this
is the same thing as the marginal social
benefit
curve but now if you think about from
society's point of view what is the
optimal price and quantity
well then you want to think about where
marginal social cost is equal to
marginal social benefit because if you
produce you want to keep producing as
long as the social benefit is higher
than the social cost but then when the
social cost is higher than the social
benefit well then that's not good then
you're going to create negative benefit
or or harm to society so it would be
rational to produce up to this quantity
this quantity
right over here so this is the optimal
quantity from a societal point of view
and this would be the optimal price from
a societal point of view but if you just
let the private markets happen as they
as as they are what happens well then
you're over producing from a societal
point of view and if you think about it
from a societal point of view this is
what is optimal but you produce all this
quantity where the marginal social cost
is higher than the marginal social
benefit
and so all of this
is going to take away from society's
benefit from the total surplus for
society and so this is going to create
dead
weight loss because these quantities are
different now we could also think about
a scenario with positive externalities
let's imagine the exercise
the let's call it let's say let's say
the
the i don't know exercise equipment
market
exercise
equipment
market we could draw similar
curves so
here we have quantity
we have price
we have our marginal private benefit
curve which would be our demand curve
so
marginal private benefit and we have our
marginal private cost curves
just like that
marginal private cost and if we just let
this market operate just thinking about
the private cost and benefit
we would
produce that quantity
and i'll say that that's just
considering the private side of things
and we would be at that price
but let's say that there's a positive
externality here so this is a pause
there's a positive externality what is
it well the more exercise equipment
that's out there the more people they're
going to exercise it's going to make
them happier it's going to lower the
health care costs and so we want we
would want to add that that benefit to
that positive externality to the
marginal private benefit curve to get
the marginal social benefit curve so
let's do that so we're going to add to
this and we're going to get the marginal
social benefit curve
marginal social benefit and let's say
the marginal social cost is the same
thing as the marginal private cost curve
marginal social
cost right over here
so if you think about what's optimal for
society society should want more and
more exercise equipment to be produced
as long as the marginal social benefit
is higher than the marginal social cost
but as soon as the marginal social cost
gets higher than the marginal social
benefit then that makes no sense that
would create negative value and so
what's optimal for society is to produce
up to that so this is the quantity
that's optimal for society this is the
price that's optimal for society but if
we just let the private benefit and cost
be what decides the equilibrium price
and quantity well we're only going to
produce this far so from a society point
of view we lost out on all of this
quantity where the marginal social
benefit is higher than the marginal
social cost so you have this dead weight
loss right over there so the big
takeaway here is when you factor in
negative external
negative externalities or positive
externalities you might discover
deadweight loss to society and so an
interesting question is to think about
how could society rectify that there are
ways to start to at least approach it